to all the underprivileged
children in the world.
( clapping )
Incredible,
Charles, really incredible.
Well, before we vote to
approve funding
for Charles' project,
it's my honor to welcome our
newest board member,
Amy BlackBerry.
Hey guys.
I know you all think I'm
here just 'cause
my dad
owns this company
and like a third of all
the phones on Earth,
but honestly, I
submitted for this job
under a fake name,
just like Tori Spelling
on "90210."
Well, regardless,
we are thrilled to have
you here.
Welcome to the team.
( clapping )
Cool... how cool.
Well, let's vote.
Oh, you know what, if I
could just interject here,
I actually had a different
plan I wanted considered
for that same funding.
I know my dad's really
behind it.
I don't want that
to affect anybody's decision,
it's just an FYI.
Okay, Amy,
yeah, go right ahead.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay, great.
Um, I have two words for
you guys.
Just two words.
"Cat park."
Huh?
Raise your hand if you've
ever heard of a dog park.
I know I have.
And now raise your hand if
you've seen a cat park?
Yeah, are you
guys with me right now?
We build the first
ever cat park,
right here
in our community.
These are the ears,
these are
the eyes, whiskers, nose.
What's missing?
The mouth.
Why is there no mouth?
Because I'm speaking
for cat park.
Pass it
around, take a swig.
Okay, some of you still have
some questions,
that's fair.
Just watch this.
♪♪
♪ Cat park
Cat Park ♪
♪♪
♪ Cat park
I like that video.
Cat park will
serve as a safe haven,
not only for cats, but for
cat owners, too?
Is this real?
Are you real?
Yes.
Okay, I get it,
"cat park."
But why now?
Why not meow?
There will be a section of
cat park with a slide
and you will
put the cat on the slide
and you can watch that cat
slide down that slide.
All right--
That kicks ass.
I know
you're all thinking,
will babies be allowed
in this park?
No, they will be arrested if
they enter the park.
This doesn't make
any sense.
Shut up, Charles.
Yeah, Charles.
Cat park.
It's simple.
Well, I mean,
it's not that simple.
No one's ever thought of
it before.
I am the first one.
Well, I don't think
we need to vote on this,
but let's
just do it for fun.
All in favor of approving
Amy's cat park?
We could have
saved millions of kids,
but after
seeing that presentation,
I don't want to
save kids.
I want
to entertain cats.
Welcome to cat park!
Thank you for the standing
ovation, everybody.
Standing O.
( clapping )
Snowball?
Rembrandt?
Where's Lady Guinevere?
( man )
Buddy?
Hey, Buddy?
( woman)
Crystal ?
Rembrandt, are you
here?
I've lost my cat!
(woman )
Mittens, I can't find you!
I can't find my cat!
( meowing )
♪♪